France Info et France 24 présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une véritable course contre la
montre qui s'engage en Ukraine car un
nouvel acteur va bientôt faire irruption
dans la guerre l'hiver et ça les
combattants en ont bien compris qu'ils
multiplient les préparatifs et les
offensifs sur des secteurs critiques que
va changer l'arrivée du froid on va
tenter d'y répondre dans ce nouveau
numéro du monde dans tous ses états avec
la spécialiste en communication Oxana
melnitchuk et ce sont bien les
infrastructures essentielles de
l'Ukraine qui sont visés derrière ces
bombardements on apparence indiscriminés
en apparence seulement ne nous y
trompons pas c'est bien la capacité des
Ukrainiens à se chauffer et s'éclairer
cet hiver qui est ciblé par les Russes
les explications en images de peggymoji
pour France Télévisions
une population qui manque de tout dans
la ville dévastée d'isium au sud de
carquif des habitants plongés dans la
misère se précipite pour récupérer de
quoi manger du pain des fruits ils
cherchent aussi de quoi se couvrir
je cherche des tricots des écharpes des
bonnets des mitaines
ni électricité
depuis lundi les frapperus sont
principalement visé les installations
énergétiques du pays ici une centrale
thermique près de Kiev
là une station électrique à vive qui a
plongé la ville dans le noir durant
plusieurs heures
selon le gouvernement ukrainien 30% des
infrastructures énergétiques ont été
détruites cette semaine
nos installations ont été endommagées
dans 12 régions et dans la capitale
l'approvisionnement en électricité a été
restaurée presque partout sauf dans
quatre régions où les travaux sont en
cours dans le don-basse les habitants de
Batman ne se font garder l'illusion
frappé de toutes parts cela fait des
mois qu'ils sont privés de tout
vous parlez d'une vie on n'a pas
d'électricité même l'eau est coupée
cette femme vit avec son époux atteint
d'un cancer ici pas d'eau pour cuisiner
ou se laver et rien pour se chauffer
le bois de chauffage comment puis-je en
avoir il n'y a aucun moyen d'en avoir
ici
je ne sais pas comment nous survivrons à
cet hiver combien de temps mon mari va
tenir
Oxana menichou on a assisté en cette fin
des terres à une contre-attaque
puissante de l'armée ukrainienne c'était
important pour Kiev de reprendre dépend
entier de son territoire avant l'arrivée
de l'hiver
oui mais vous savez l'arrivée de l'hiver
pour l'Hermès sans rien parce que c'est
pas une guerre de l'armée une fantérie
c'est une guerre de l'artillerie donc
altère les riz il s'en fout d'où l'hiver
ou pas l'hiver même le fameux enlisement
raspoutit ça comme on dit ça c'est
approprié à la Russie l'Ukraine c'est
quand même c'est une pays où le climat
elle est comparable avec la France il
reste petit ça on oublie qu'est-ce que
c'est nous avons les routes qui sont
bien faites
dans la boue comme on dit nous n'en
voyons pas les chars dans les bouts
c'est les Russes comme ils savent pas
mener la guerre comme il faut il envoie
leur charte dans les boues nous nous
avons une autre manière mener la guerre
néanmoins leur tourne c'est ce qu'on
comprit les Occidentaux en livrant
davantage d'armes aux Ukrainiens ces
dernières semaines mais oui bien sûr
parce que comme j'ai dit déjà que c'est
une guerre de l'air tellurie donc on a
besoin vraiment beaucoup de domicile
beaucoup beaucoup
le cours des événements en faveur des
Ukrainiens
nous avons besoin de cette arme de
langue n'est pas pour l'utiliser sur le
territoire russe mais pour que les
Russes sachent que nous avons cette
matériel pour éviter le bombardement qui
font maintenant à partir de la mer
Caspienne sur le crâne ce concombre
c'est qu'il fallait désormais viser les
moyens qu'elle l'Ukraine de s'alimenter
en énergie d'où vaporidja annexés par
par les Russes cette centrale la plus
grande d'Europe doit aussi les attaques
contre les centrales thermiques et
électriques en Ukraine oui ils vise
toute une phrase structure énergétique
parce que c'est pas uniquement à la
guerre militaire c'est aussi guère de
l'énergie c'est la guerre de la
communication
dans les villages et les villes qui ont
été occupées ou qui sont encore occupés
par les Russes jusqu'à 90% de la
population à fuient et pour celles et
ceux qui restent et bien ils passeront
l'hiver dans des conditions indiennes ce
dont les autorités ukrainiennes ont très
peur c'est la répétition de ces frappes
massives de Moscou contre les
infrastructures électriques de fait
lundi et mardi 1/3 de ces centrales
électriques ont été frappés privant une
partie du pays de courant d'électricité
d'eau chaude mais également de gaz alors
du côté militaire et bien de ce côté là
les soldats tentent de récupérer le plus
de territoires possibles avant la
raspoutit ça vous savez c'est cette
période de l'année où il pleut tellement
que le sol se transforme en Gadou dans
laquelle s'enlise les chars et les
blindés alors l'automne risque donc de
figer les positions d'un côté comme de
l'autre privant l'armée ukrainienne de
ce momentum extrêmement important pour
cette contre-offensive
en temps normal déjà hors période de
guerre comme on l'observe aujourd'hui
comment s'organise la vie des Ukrainiens
durant les hivers est-ce qu'ils sont
aussi rigoureux qu'en Russie
c'est quoi c'est le climat c'est
comparable à celle de la France à l'est
de l'Ukraine de nietz qui est élégance
c'est un peu plus froid parce que c'est
plus profond non notre univers commence
à partir de 21 25 novembre pas avant
maintenant nous avons les mêmes temps
qu'à Paris il fait plus ou moins beau et
chaud il pleut pas si les vers
s'installe c'est zéro -3 - 2 degrés donc
c'est on peut survivre c'est pas les
Sibérie c'est pas moins 15 - 20 qui qui
nous attend on espère bien que les
pronostics du temps vont être plutôt
positif la difficulté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui 6 millions de d'ukrainien
sont déplacés intérieurs et on les
imagine pour beaucoup mal logés mal
isolé ça c'est vrai et le gouvernement
ukrainien ils ont déjà fait un appel
Jean de La de l'Est qu'il s'approche
plutôt vers le crâne
occidental et centre de l'Ukraine ou le
chauffage est assuré parce que notre
gouvernement ne peut pas assurer le
chauffage sur les territoires qui
viennent d'être des deux occupés parce
que toutes les phrases structures et
c'est vrai qu'elle est détruite
complètement avec la guerre on l'a vu
aussi il y a ces attaques contre ces
infrastructures or en 48 heures les
autorités l'affirment les
approvisionnements énergétiques sont
déjà stabilisés c'est vrai il faut le
croire c'est vrai parce que nous avons
les nouveaux technologies vous savez je
voudrais rassurer notre spectateur les
armées ils gagnent les batailles mais
les guerres ils sont gagnées par les
technologies l'Ukraine il est beaucoup
plus avancé en technologie que la Russie
l'Occident il a encore plus avancé donc
je pense que les efforts solidaires de
l'Ukraine avec l'Europe occidentale nous
permettra à gagner sa guerre grâce aux
technologies c'est un facteur tellement
important sur le champ de bataille en
tout cas on lui a même donné un nom dans
le langage populaire le général
incarnation presque humaine de cet homme
qui fut décisif pour la Russie puis pour
l'URSS face aux troupes napoléoniennes
et aux nazis Juliette Prigent
replongeons dans nos cours d'histoire et
remonter en 1812 les troupes de Napoléon
entame leur retraite et se retrouvent
près de la rivière Bérézina dans
l'actuel Biélorussie et là ils sont
confrontés au froid -30°c mais surtout à
la boue qui les empêche d'avancer bref
c'est un carnage comme le montre les
tableaux de l'époque et ce n'est
d'ailleurs pas pour rien que
l'expression c'est une Bérézina est
entrée dans le vocabulaire actuel pour
caractériser une déroute sur le plan
sportif ou électorale en fait ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'en Russie il existe
deux périodes dans l'année appelé les
raspoutitsa ou les plus automnales ou la
neige fondue au printemps et bien crée
énormément de boue et rend les sols
impraticable c'est d'ailleurs ça qui a
empêché l'armée allemande de progresser
contre les Soviétiques lors de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale on le sait donc
l'hiver va jouer un rôle crucial dans la
guerre en Ukraine on ne sait pas encore
à qui elle va bénéficier aux Russes ou
aux Ukrainiens
et les leçons l'histoire les Russes le
savent ça Occident aussi c'est votre
patrimoine commun d'une certaine manière
c'est notre patrimoine avec vous aussi
parce que Bérézina vous savez Bérézina
pour Napoléon ne commençait pas à la
frontière elle a commencé quand elle est
refusé le stratégique qui lui était
proposé par certains généraux de
commencer la guerre contre les Russie en
passant par l'Ukraine il a trouvé cette
plante inacceptable tandis que s'il
passait par le crâne bon mais
malheureusement l'histoire
parce que l'histoire de respecter de ça
c'est parce que les Ukrainiens
soutenaient plutôt Napoléon dans cette
guerre et comme ça la guerre pourrait
avoir une autre retournée mais bon
l'histoire ne connaît pas les
conditionnel donc Raspoutine ça c'est
vraiment le mot russe qui signifie
absence des routes c'est pas le cas à
l'Ukraine en Ukraine les routes ils sont
presque comme en France l'année dernière
on a lancé une énorme projet national
c'est les nouveaux nouveaux routes et
tout était beaucoup déjà il y avait
beaucoup de choses qui étaient déjà
faites donc l'artillerie il s'en fout
des routes l'artillerie c'est la
longueur du tir qui compte et c'est
aussi c'est la guerre des drones c'est
la quantités des drones qui comptent
c'est pas les chars qui qui sont
décisifs
dans un instant vous le disiez les les
en tout cas les missiles et notamment
les capacités de tir à longue portée ont
en partie changer la donne sur le
sentiment et notamment liée à l'hiver
même si les moins rigoureux à mesure
qu'on s'éloigne vers l'ouest il va
néanmoins gagner aussi cette partie du
monde ici en Europe est-ce que ça
pourrait décourager d'après vous le
soutien qu'apporte les Européens aux
Ukrainiens est-ce qu'avec les pénuries
de gaz et d'électricité dont on entend
parler ici même au sein de l'Union
européenne on pourrait être d'après vous
tenter de se dire finalement à quoi bon
souffrir pour l'Ukraine vous le craignez
ça mais on se fera pas pour le crâne on
souffre pour nous tous parce que c'est
pas la guerre à l'Ukraine c'est la
guerre en Europe pour l'Europe c'est
vous avez bien vu tous le discours de
Poutine il a annoncé la guerre et
l'Occident c'est le mode de vivre à
l'Occident qu'il ne supporte pas c'est
le mot de c'est le monde du droit
international qu'il supporte pas il a
dit dans son discours qui a fait cet
ordre qui a fait cet ordre international
c'est c'est
délire leur l'ordre international donc
Poutine il n'a aucune respect pour ça
c'est pas la guerre pour le crâne c'est
la guerre pour l'Europe et c'est à nous
12 battes ensemble nous nous sommes nous
sommes souliers chars sur les missiles
vous vous êtes sous les factures c'est
beaucoup plus facile à survivre que les
Ukrainiens se battent pour nous c'est
notre ligne de front à nous européen
c'est la première ligne de front
l'Ukraine c'est notre première ligne de
front qui est chaud mais les lignes du
front elle est partout il est dans les
cerveaux il est dans la communication il
est dans les économies aussi parce que
la guerre et la déclaré à toute l'ordre
qui suit le internationale donc si on
cède une centimètre là après
toute morde toute l'ordre de droit
international va s'écrouler et comme un
symbole en tout cas de la volonté des
Ukrainiens de résister malgré l'hiver le
chanteur seattoslave vacard chouk a
publié sur Twitter cette vidéo ils vont
en train de chanter sur un pont rester
debout à Kiev malgré les bombardements
de lundi dernier un pont fait du métal
d'azoft stalles à Syrie de Mario Paul où
c'était réfugié les derniers soldats
ukrainiens et des habitants sa chanson
leur est d'ailleurs dédié extrait
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette première partie du
monde dans tous ses étangs se retrouvent
dans un instant juste après un journal
sur France 24
[Musique]
France Info et France 24 présente
suite du monde dans tous ses états en
quoi l'hiver peut changer la donne en
Ukraine on continue d'en parler avec la
spécialiste en communication que ça
n'amène ni de choc on l'a décrite comme
un nouveau tournant dans cette guerre-là
contre-offensive que ment actuellement
les forces ukrainiennes et ce depuis
début septembre des villes reprises au
Sud et à l'Est parti de la région et de
carquif les Ukrainiens repoussent
l'armée russe au port du Dombasle comme
à couper en dessous pour France 24
Gwendoline de Bono
une colonne de fumée s'élève de la
banlieue de coupiance tout juste
reconquise par les troupes ukrainiennes
avec les raquettes les canons Ukrainiens
prennent désormais position sur les
hauteurs les habitants ne prêtent plus
attention au départ de fou
beaucoup partent leur ville est détruite
est loin d'être sécurisé
les positions des militaires
avec les petites groupes militaires là
se situe l'enjeu pour les Ukrainiens
continuer la contre-offensive tout en
sécurisant les arrières nous sommes dans
la base d'un bataillon des forces
spéciales ukrainiennes c'est ce
bataillon qui a cassé les premières
lignes de défense russe et ces hommes
continuent aujourd'hui la
contre-offensive le major clever son
surnom et l'un des commandants du
bataillon les Russes selon lui montrent
toujours la même faiblesse
chez nous les décisions de terrain sont
prises rapidement par les commandants
qui sont sur le terrain ils ont toute
l'attitude pour décider
l'armée russe est toujours fixée sur un
système vertical s'ils n'ont pas le feu
vert du plus haut gradé l'infanterie ne
bouge pas c'est ce qui nous permet de
les aplatir
une cinquantaine de kilomètres au sud au
lexandre émiratello surveille les berges
de loskill la rivière coule jusqu'à la
région du don-basse
[Musique]
accompliant les Ukrainiens sont parvenus
à la traversée mais ici c'est encore la
ligne de front
une balle siffle à proximité ils nous
ont tiré dessus ici hier
c'est la position 0 en face c'est les
connards de russe notre rôle c'est de
surveiller que personne ne traverse ou
ne repère nos positions pour que notre
artillerie et notre armement ne soient
pas détruit on ne doit pas laisser
passer leur groupe de reconnaissance on
veille aussi à ce que les Russes qui
n'ont pas eu le temps de s'enfuir sur
l'autre côté de la rive ne s'approche
pas ne prospective
ah ça c'est les tirs de leur tank
loin de leur ligne nombre de soldats
russes sont encore bloqués côté
ukrainien
des soldats russes en déroute occènes
Michu qu'il y en a beaucoup dont Moscou
n'a plus de nouvelles aujourd'hui ah si
il y a les nouvelles de Moscou
maintenant on a commencé tout ce qu'on
appelle oblave ça veut dire que on
frappe les gens on attrape les gens dans
la rue et on les met dans les zones qui
s'appelle le stock où on met toutes les
gens qui ont rattrape dans la rue où les
hommes qui sont susceptibles en armée et
jusqu'à la fin
on les envoie après au commissariat pour
envoyer à la guerre et ceux qui se
retrouvent comme on l'a vu dans ce
reportage finalement perdu presque dans
des dans des dans des buissons
il y en a beaucoup oui il y a beaucoup
qui se rendent
et qui seront les désertaires et puis
les autres qui par exemple j'ai lu tout
à l'heure que il y avait une brigade à
qui on a donné l'ordre prendre la
position dans le champ
les meilleurs
expériences de le temps les armes aussi
font la différence elles fournies par
les Occidentaux
les différences les différents je vais
vous dire les différences entre l'armée
ukrainien et les Russes parce que
l'ermocrinien russe comme vous avez dit
il est gouverné il y a une hiérarchie
pyramidale qui est très stricte tu peux
pas prendre la décision sur place il
faut toujours attendre l'ordre du dos
tandis que l'armée ukrainienne et les
fonctions par les pitié de groupe et les
diviser par les petites groupes qui
contrôlent certains territoires et la
décision est prise selon la situation
absolument autonome parce qu'il y a une
confiance entre le général il est
commandant qui sont sur place nous
disiez les armes aussi font la
différence justement où en sont les
livraisons d'armes Juliette Prigent
après les bombardements en Ukraine ce
sont la livraison d'armes de défense
anti-aériennes qui se sont accélérés et
les Allemands en premier qui ont livré
le premier des quatre systèmes de
défense aérien irisé SLM ce sont ces
missiles qui ont une portée de 40 km sur
une altitude de 20 km les Ukrainiens qui
devraient aussi recevoir des missiles
solaires appelés nasams des Américains
ce sont ces missiles là qui ont eux une
portée beaucoup plus grande de 180 km et
Joe Biden a annoncé qu'il accélère
accélérait la livraison afin de protéger
les Ukrainiens à leur tour les Français
et les Anglais ont annoncé envoyer des
radars des systèmes des missiles et des
munitions de défense anti-aériennes et
tout ça en fait ça a pour objectif de
créer des dômes de fer ou des bulles de
protection en fait des zones presque
impénétrables regardez en moins de 10
secondes ces missiles sont capables de
détecter des missiles de croisière
ennemies et vont pouvoir les neutraliser
en plein vol comme ici on le voit sur
l'image ça existe déjà en Israël et à
Washington et ça devrait faire son
apparition dans les plus grandes villes
ukrainiennes
espagnols aussi ont donné leur
contribution ces systèmes entiers
aériens ils sont essentiels comme l'ont
montré ces derniers jours que ça n'amène
vous savez notre président et le réclame
depuis octobre de la dernière et là
parce que les cieux que la guerre se
prépare et pourquoi d'après vous les
Russes attendus pour bombarder aussi
massivement qu'ils l'ont fait ces
derniers jours
déjà parce qu'il faut qu'il préserve
leur arme et non pas assez vous savez
ils ont déjà 28% de tout ce qu'ils ont
eu le 24 février donc il faut il fallait
les économiser ils ont compté toujours
que la l'armée russe sur le champ du
bataille
mais comme c'est fini déjà pour sur les
chambres des batailles maintenant c'est
c'est transporté sur la guerre de
l'artellerie et ils vont déstocker de
toute façon ils n'ont rien à perdre
parce que ils vont ils vont ils vont
déstocker son stock parce que ils savent
bien ils sont bien que les yeux de la
guerre et les claires mais ceux qui la
question qui se posait dans les
Ukrainiens pourquoi l'Occident pourquoi
l'Europe attend pour fournir toutes ces
armes là tandis que si on l'aurait au
début de la guerre on évitera toutes les
victimes et toutes les pertes qui ont eu
depuis un soutien qui repose aussi sur
les opinions publiques quand on aide
l'Ukraine à hauteur de plus de 65
milliards de dollars comme annoncé par
les États-Unis eux-mêmes comment
réagissent les citoyens américains ils
se sentent concernés par la guerre en
Ukraine Thomas Donzel à Washington pour
France Télévisions
les Américains continuent de suivre
cette guerre en Ukraine 66% d'entre eux
déclarcis intéressés avec une crainte la
crainte d'une escalade 58% des
Américains pensent que ce conflit va
devenir un conflit nucléaire avec la
Russie mais malgré cette crainte ils
sont aussi encore une large majorité à
soutenir les livraisons d'armes à
l'Ukraine décidé par l'administration de
Joe Biden les deux tiers des Américains
soutiennent ces livraisons d'armes alors
malgré ce soutien et c'est intérêt
apparent il faut nuancer un petit peu
les choses car pour les Américains les
questions de politique internationale ne
sont pas la priorité ici le conflit en
Ukraine semble très lointain il n’y a
pas de risque par exemple de coupure
d'approvisionnement en gaz les
Américains disposent de larges réserves
avec l'exploitation des gaz de schiste
et puis il n'y a pas de danger non plus
d'après les Américains que la Russie
attaque directement leur territoire à ce
stade du conflit non pour les Américains
la priorité ce sont les questions
économiques c'est l'inflation c'est
l'inflation galopante ici encore plus
qu'en Europe et puis ce sont les
questions de société avec par exemple le
droit à l'avortement qui a été remis en
cause au niveau fédéral par une décision
de la Cour suprême au mois de juin
dernier ce sont ces questions là qui
sont au centre des débats avant les
élections de mi-mandat ce sera dans un
mois à peine le 8 novembre prochain ce
sont ces questions là nationales
économiques et sociétales qui sont au
cœur des préoccupations des Américains
et pas la guerre en Ukraine
et derrière cette course aux armes
conventionnelles il y a une crainte dans
tous les esprits l'usage du nucléaire
fréquemment brandi par Vladimir Poutine
depuis le début de son invasion une
menace qu'on croyait remise et au rang
des vestiges de l'Union soviétique
retour en arrière c'était en 1949 le
monde stupéfait découvre qu'après les
États-Unis l'URSS à son tour dispose
désormais de l'art atomique l'équilibre
de la terreur est née
[Musique]
l'URSS à la bombe la nouvelle est
maintenant officielle et Monsieur André
Labarthe observateur français à bikini
en tire les premières déductions il y a
deux mois le 29 juillet 1949 un
hebdomadaire français annonçait au monde
l'URSS à la bombe
c'était trois ans après bikini jour pour
jour le monde a été surpris par la
rapidité avec laquelle le RSS a réalisé
la bombe c'est-à-dire avec laquelle elle
a dû construire les immenses
laboratoires les usines gigantesques les
autridge les losses à la Mosses les
reinesford que j'ai longuement visité
désormais le rythme avec lequel la
Russie produira des bombes atomiques
dépend uniquement de l'ampleur des
moyens industriels qu'elle entend y
consacrer
Hiroshima Nagasaki puis c'est non
rappelé au gouvernement leur terrible
responsabilité au moment où le problème
nucléaire échappante au contrôle d'une
seule nation atteint véritablement à
l'échelle mondiale
[Musique]
quand vous voyez ces images vous
regrettez vous que l'Ukraine et du
sacrifice sont propres arsenal nucléaire
sur l'hôtel de son indépendance
toujours une vente quelque chose pour
tuer les autres même Léonard de DaVinci
était
approprié à énormément
on regrette vous savez le mot marrant
donc de Budapest ça c'est l'origine de
conflit parce que quand l'Ukraine elle a
rendu son armement nucléaire et l'a
rendu
au contraire et la demander la
contrepartie il a demandé la ligarantie
de sécurité les États-Unis étaient
illégra et Grande-Bretagne étaient les
signataires de cette garantie donc toute
l'aide maintenant militaire qui est
donnée par les angles Saxon c'est un peu
la récompense si vous voulez parce que
on a on devait être à
l'abriant vos armes nucléaires et vous
n'êtes pas aujourd'hui récompensé d'une
certaine manière par la Russie qui ne
respecte pas sa parole si on vous avait
dit un jour que le monde est vous-même
ukrainien auriez à vous préoccuper de
l'usage de la nucléaire par la Russie en
l'occurrence par Vladimir Poutine vous
qui les connaissez bien vous auriez cru
non mais c'était imagine imaginable même
le 23 février on n'a pas on croyait pas
que les Russes ont commencé la guerre
contre nous à tel point on a on a pensé
qu'il y avait 21e siècle c'est pas
possible mais c'est possible parce que
nous avons l'affaire avec le Tirane et
le tiram il ne comprend pas une seule
langue que l'angle de la force il faut
donner la réponse
d'avoir été avec nous on arrive au terme
de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez la retrouver
sur notre site internet france info.fr
France 24.com rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour le monde dans tous ses
états
[Musique]